un américain un danois un allemand trois
jihadistes trois jihadistes étrangers
renvoyés vers leur pays était détenu par
la turquie et sur la liste des turcs
il y a également aux djihadistes rance
et les femmes pour l'essentiel détenu
jusqu alors dans des camps kurdes
faut-il accepter faute il enclenché le
bras de fer
voici deux points de vue avant de
connaître les vôtres et d'en débattre
avec nos invités
celui de l'eurodéputé rn jordan bardella
l'autre de l'ancien procureur de paris
françois molins nous étions nous opposer
au retour des djihadistes parce que se
pose la question de la manière dont on
va juger des gens en droit français les
très compliqué de juger des gens pour
des crimes ou des délits qui ont été
commis à l'étranger sur les enfants je
crois que c'est du cas par cas et une
différence à faire entre un nourrisson
de 1 ou 2 ans et un gamin de six ou sept
ans qui s'est déjà utilisé une
kalachnikov c'est normal de j'allais
dire d'avoir un sujet d'inquiétude quand
on voit le mal qu'on fait tous ces gens
là à travers les organisations
terroristes de dèche et d'al qaïda
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la justice française a les moyens à
travers tous les mandats qui ont été
délivrés de traiter judiciairement les
hommes et les femmes qui reviendront sur
territoire français il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir vis-à-vis de la
capacité de la justice française a
traité ces hommes et ces femmes qui sera
expulsé par la turquie dans le cadre des
protocoles casse 9
je sais pas si c'est rassurer mais je
trouve ça assez convaincant en tout cas
puisque moi ce contenu il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui ont quand même changé
d'avis sur cette question l' an dernier
par exemple si on évoquait le retour
possible de jihadistes en france pour
être jugé en france c'était avait des
hurlements etc et j'ai entendu l'autre
jour guillaume roquette directeur du
figaro magazine
dire que finalement
après discussion avec des militaires
secrets il disait qu au fond peut-être
on les contrôlerait mieux effectivement
les accueillants et en les jugeant en
france que s'il y reviennent en ordre
dispersé en fait dans la nature
donc voilà maintenant on aimerait savoir
comment dire sous quelle chef quel sera
le chef d'inculpation est ce que c'est
votre trahison le choix c'est ce que
j'ai vu que ça en prison en france soit
en liberté en france séduction en prison
en france
mais c'est choisir tout ce qu'il vaut
mais qui sont en prison en france ou en
prison en syrie aux prises en irak et au
mexique en prison en syrie ou en irak
c'est ça que c'est ça le sujet donc
c'est évident que si on part du principe
qu'un gars qui seraient libérés parce
que les kurdes peuvent parce qu'on a
lâché les kurdes que donc les kurdes qui
les gardait ne peuvent que les garder
que monsieur rigole nous les rangs on
change d'avis parce qu'en fait on n'a
pas le choix et donc s'ils doivent leur
revenir et qui vont reviennent il vaut
mieux les mettre au trou mais de là à
dire que c'est une bonne chose qu'ils
reviennent vous paraît c'est simplement
que ils reviennent parce qu'il revienne
et qu'on n'y peut rien parce qu'on se
vis-à-vis des airs de l'annoncé pas
qu'on sait pas quoi faire le fond c'est
qu'on est absolument des armées ils sont
doit faire savoir dogan moi je suis un
petit peu étonné d'abord je rappelle en
fait qu'à une procédure c'est à dire que
la france a fait un accord avec erdogan
s'est pas erdogan sait que nous sommes
comme toujours les responsables de notre
propre mot nos propres mots c'est la
procédure cazeneuve
ainsi il aura droit quant à la probable
procédure quasiment vie doivent revenir
mais la passion qui relève de la
provocation dans la posture casse 9
s'appliquer ressortissants français qui
étaient irréguliers en turquie pas ceux
qui étaient en syrie ou en irak
oui mais parce qu'ils sont passés non
alors seul et même qu'il ressent bien
qu'ils sont là le procureur mme hollins
bien le dire ils reviennent bien au non
un petit 1 excusez moi mais chat échaudé
craint l'eau froide
si la justice française n'avait fait
aucune erreur pierre de terrorisme
je serai rassuré il se trouve qu'il ya
trop de cas de gens qu'on a un peu qui
sont passés sous les radars mais surtout
plus important je m'étonne toujours que
des gens notamment de gauche défendent
le principe d'extraterritorialité
c'est à dire que nous ressortissants
devraient être jugés en france et non
dans l'endroit où ils ont commis des
crimes
je vous rappelle que ça c'etait un
colonial qui faisait que les
ressortissants européens a été jugé en
france et non pas dans le pays où vous
avez commis des crimes
et voilà encore un de ces paradoxes de
notre monde de folie nous demandons la
gauche française anti colonialiste
demande à ce que des gens qui ont commis
des crimes au moyen orient soient jugés
en france c'est à dire soit exonéré de
leurs responsabilités là où ils ont été
fautifs
voilà terrible typiquement une
revendication colonialiste si les mots
ont un sens juste sur ça et fokam pour
préciser dans les deux sens de carole
c'est qu'effectivement il ya un certain
nombre d'experts de l'anti terrorisme
jean-charles bozor qui est venu ici à
plusieurs reprises qui explique que le
danger c'est la porosité des des prisons
des camps des camps kurdes
c'est peut-être la présence porosité de
certaines prisons irakiennes
et si on les a sur les rapatrie ici on
sait au moins et tribunal alibert parce
que de toute façon on dira que c'est la
femme l'a pas fait grand chose et puis
toi sont à baalbeck qu'on a 10 ans
qu'elle en fera 5 mai dans 5 elle sera
dehors bon on sait qu'en syrie ou à
venir à côté que ce soit bien présent
pour va pas ils bougeront pas pendant 20
ans donc bah voilà c'est comme ça
rachel je crois qu'en effet le risque
c'est que on a vu à quel point notre
état pouvait être fragile à quel point
il eût été très difficile de suivre les
individus pourtant avec un risque
extrêmement élevé or je sais pas où ça
en est là la mosquée de connaissent mais
lui-même était toujours en place et
encore et encore quinze jours donc il
est normal qu'on ait une crainte sur le
sort que l'on va leur réserver avec en
plus derrière une espèce de données
comme que ce douloureux
oui oui le discours humanitaire un petit
peu ces dispositifs législatifs et même
les distille des dispositifs bien sûr
qu'on a les moyens vraiment dans l'ue de
les mettre en prison et dans ce cas là
en prison
l'idée c'est qu'il n'ait aucun rapport
avec aucun autre prisonnier parce qu'on
sait qu'elles sont et chris kelly et
france 8 ans hier 10
qu'il ya des places qui ont été dégagés
pour pouvoir les écouter
moi je devrais a fait revenir le
procureur mollins au premier incident
d'accord aux djihadistes que ce sera à
échapper aux djihadistes qui aurait été
qui sera sorti de prison qui aura commis
un attentat terroriste
et je voudrais qu'on réécoute à ce
moment là cette interview et en se
disant peut-être qu'il aurait mieux
connu ma capable de faire des cartes et
les gardiens de brison islamistes alors
vous pensez
mais c'est quand même ça la vérité
aujourd'hui dans les prisons il ya des
gardiens de prison qui sont islamistes
on ne peut pas les virées de la
pénitentiaire en échange de prison donc
bon moi je voudrais bien avoir confiance
est formidable mais enfin bon
fraîchement il ya quand même pas mal
d'exemples qui provoqua par un tribunal
international enfin franchement là on
aurait des garanties de droit sauf que
maintenant monsieur erdogan a décidé de
nous les rendre parce qu'il veut nous
punir de par2 de la sphère kurde et je
pense pour d'autres raisons
c'est en fait on a des hommes sur place
qu'il fallait six fascine pas la tâche
c'est ça la vérité c'est pas uniquement
parce qu'on ai dit que c'était pas bien
ce qu'ils faisaient aux kurdes
je pense qu'il avoue comprendre qu'il en
dise c'est ce qu'on fait à sa tombe
d'autres pays là on retombe sur nos
propres errements encore une fois
toujours notre tendance à aller dire
c'est la faute aux autres
mais pensez bien que des pays qui ont
supprimé la double nationalité et bien
erdogan ça vient se produire alors ne
peut pas renvoyer les gens chez eux
puisqu'ils n'ont plus de nationalité de
ce pays d'origine si nous avions
supprimer la double nationalité ça a été
un débat à cette table n'est ce pas si
nous avions et à ça donc de ces
djihadistes voir la majorité d'entre eux
ne pourraient pas rentrer en france
car ils ne seraient plus français donc
nous nous sommes mis nous mêmes
comment dirais-je dans le sac de scapin
vous souvenez vous pouvez rafraîchir la
mémoire mal hier un bol d'air but
d'henry mais vous me dire de quelle
fourberie cela
je vous pose ajouté je vous prends au
mot
christophe vous devez de l'explication
pour reprendre
justement ce débat mais qu'est-ce qui
ont se plaint bon mettons que
on déplore cette situation qu'est ce que
le gouvernement doit faire ce qu'il
voulait on peut faire ce que ministère
des affaires étrangères va faire par
rapport à par rapport à la turquie qui
nous qui menace aujourd'hui de ces
renvois et peut-être demain deux peuvent
ouvrir encore plus ses frontières ce
qu'ils ont deux armes
il y a les réfugiés d'une part et
maintenant les terroristes et il joue
tsahal gaughan dès qu'on le mécontentent
il appuie la ouvre les frontières et
puis les voiliers de réfugiés qui
arrivent on sait plus comment gérer
alors en l'événement d'europe
il referme et puis maintenant ils disent
que j'ai encore mieux je vous envoie le
terrorisme fidèles soutiens il est le
septième de la trempe là encore rappelé
je croyais rend ce matin mais il a il a
à nouveau répété que la turquie était un
allié des états unis et qu'il valait
mieux l'avoir ressemblent autant qu'à
l'extérieur
et pour lui voilà c'est l'un des états
stables de cette zone de cette zone là
et l'alliance continue je vous pose la
question différemment c'est d'ailleurs
cet internaute qui la posent la question
n'est évidemment pas de savoir si on
veut ou s'il faudrait s'y opposer et
bien savoir si on peut signer risée
ayrault dénonce le protocole cazeneuve
déjà fait ça dépend de nos ondes et
qu'on dénonce ce protocole voilà et on
demande à ce que les gens soient jugés
et ce qui est conforme au droit
international sur place le risque étant
que moi je te son ballet qui peuvent
plus
le garder les nôtres on ouvre les pores
et bien cela à ce moment là il sera
temps de voter notre fameuse loi qui
traînent sur l'a12 la déchéance de
nationalité mais ils surviennent en
fraude sur verre parce que le risque
qu'ils reviennent
et s'ils n'ont pas la double nationalité
ça sert à rien on peut pas rendre
quelqu'un apatrides endroit en droit
international
et s'il recommençait n'aura non mais je
demande à voir de combien ont une double
nationalité
ok déjà ce serait vers le reggae samba
sow loquace il faut se charge dont le
mais on peut citer il faut s'attaquer à
ceux qui ont au moins la double
nationalité je vous signale que erdogan
n'a pas en renvoyer attendre de gens qui
avaient été déchus de leur nationalité
dans plusieurs pays d'europe
parce que justement il ne pouvait pas le
faire carole le mot de la fin vous
retourner leur faire nos courses c'est
compliqué d'avoir un avis sur cette
question à partir du moment où l'état
lui même semble ne pas en avoir mais
c'est à dire comme sur beaucoup de
sujets mais non mais moi je rappelle
quand même le discours de manuel macron
après l'attentât de la préfecture de
police
j'étais pas finalement grand chose et il
appelait à la société de vigilance donc
on a l'impression qu'il ya une sorte
d'impuissance de l'état et sur tous ces
sujets là notamment
c'est sur ces propos rassurants rupture
cette partie là et on continuera le
débat demain dans les décrypteurs avec
un débat entre jean michel faubert
justement et le député maire eric diard
pour savoir justement quatre ans après
où on est la menace où on est la
protection de la france est avec un
sujet très fort d'ailleurs signé
stéphane foltzer sur comment
la france et les services français
essaye de s'organiser pour déjouer les
attentats la cgt